Jorge Ramos is an anchor at Univision
news and fusion television and he joins
us tonight all right thanks for coming
up
thank you I never imagined that I would
be on Fox News listening to you
criticizing President Trump on
immigration but thanks for inviting me
it's a matter of the principle and this
is the principle which is that a country
has a right to determine who enters it
and who gets citizenship who votes who
chooses the government that's what a
country is and I can't imagine how you
could publicly disagree with that and
yet you seem to know what I what I also
agree soccer is that we have an
immigration problem I think we all agree
with that
there are 11 million people who are here
illegally and they are here because of
us and they are harvesting the food that
we eat they're building our homes
they're taking care of our kids and we
have to find a solution and president
Trump surprisingly I don't trust him I
don't believe him but surprisingly in
this meeting he said he wants
comprehensive immigration reform you and
I remember this is year 2000 that
whenever we say comprehensive
immigration reform that means legalizing
11 million people in this country and if
the president wants to do that I'm all
for it however I'm not sure that
tomorrow President Trump is going to
come with a tweet or with an interview
and change and challenge your premise
which is deeply disingenuous and that is
that it's somehow our fault corporately
all of our fault that 11 million people
snuck in the country are now demanding
that it's not it's not no that's not
true it's not because of me it's not
because most people I know it's because
a small number of employers wanted to
pay less for labor and the Democratic
Party wanted new voters I didn't do that
and there's no reason that I should have
to live under a government controlled by
people who came here illegally why
should I they're here they're here
because of you and me it's simply a
matter of supply in the manner they're
huge simply because there are jobs for
them and also we have to admit because
in Latin America they make maybe five
dollars a day
and they can make direct exact amount of
money here in just a few hours but we
are responsible for them and so we're
responsive swords were to become
successful
because we have taken the time to build
a functioning country a clean safe
country with a working justice system
and a thriving economy then we are
somehow morally required to let anybody
who wants to come here come and we can't
complain about it how does that work
exactly no because every day every time
you you go to a hotel every time you go
to a restaurant they're helping you they
are working for us they're working for
the companies that want to pay less
that's why they hired them and the owner
of those companies make a lot of money
and we get to pay higher taxes in order
to support them living here just just
for a while but for instance the
National Academy of Sciences recently
conducted a study and they concluded
that in this country but rather rather
than throw around fake numbers I'd
rather get to the principle though you
make a fair point which is supply and
demand is driving this there are people
who want to hire illegally for sure
you're absolutely right there it's not
me but it some employers do but why
should American citizens who buy large
are not responsible for illegal
immigration have to live in a country
where people who sneak in illegally get
the vote and determine who runs their
government I don't understand no other
country would allow do we all benefit
from that and then of course on
comprehensive immigration reform if if
it's true what President Trump is is
proposing I don't think he's telling the
truth or that he even understand what's
happening here
then they might have the opportunity
ventually in decades from now to vote or
not that's not the issue at this point
we're not even discussing problems very
much the issue for any an American
citizen I I don't want to be governed by
people who snuck into the country but
let me ask you this if you come here
legally now you're demanding the people
who came illegally have the right to be
here legally and get citizenship why
those people be allowed to bring their
relatives from a foreign country where's
that about chain migration now
everything change my great majority of
immigration is chain language so it's
not as it's called actually it's called
family reunification what I mean it's
the same you enjoy do you enjoy spending
time with your family Tucker serious
matter to participate in in theory let
me just ask why this country should you
have a right to bring your relatives
let's say that let's just say that you
do well immigrants do too and they do
enjoy spending time with their families
and since 1965 and this was inspired by
JFK before he died since 1965 the policy
that we have here in the United States
favors family reunification and bringing
those who have special talents to this
country recipients have special talents
nobody's even more doctor recipients
know there whatever young for that okay
- young for that policy why should it
continue to be the policy that's that's
the question why is it a wise policy
because I think it's a wise policy I
think has worked well for this country
just see the number of CEOs immigrants
or sons of immigrants who are leading
major companies in in this country I
think when when when president from uses
the term chain migration those are code
words he's really saying you know I
don't want more immigrants from Asia or
Latin America coming to this country I
want to stop that and what I want to
make America white here you know what
you're doing because what you're doing
rather than engage in an adult argument
using reason you're accusing people you
disagree with a bigotry which is a
little much actually considering that
you're demanding that Americans who were
born here letting people who snuck in
illegally and all their family and if
they say anything about it they're
racist game actually a migration or
family reunification it doesn't matter
that that's a law of the land is now how
would you feel
States exported love the poorest 10% of
its population to Mexico export that
poorest 10% of its population to Mexico
completely changed the mix of Mexico the
politics of Mexico and undercut the
wages of Mexican citizens and then if
anyone complained about it said well
you're just a racist would you think
that was kind of a stick up I I
understand what's happening in Mexico
and it's terrible what's happening in
Mexico I cannot defend and I do not
defend what's happening in Mexico
absolutely not
is that is that was that your question
jabo Radek time sadly but I know that we
will meet again all right thank you for
joining us thanks doctor